farmers in the village of kalayaji can
do nothing
as water levels drop the canals
connected to wells
through which they were irrigating their
fields have run dry
the wheat is growing at a slow pace and
as water has become even more scarce
farmers worry there may be no harvest
season this year
we worry a lot we worry if this water
gets scarcer
where will we go we're very concerned
about where we should go
but let's see what god will decide for
us
half of afghanistan's provinces have
been gripped by a drought crisis
and climate change is being blamed
there's been limited snowfall and rain
both vital
during the spring and summer farming
seasons
humanitarian organizations are warning
that people
in many parts of afghanistan face
severe water shortages including
drinking water
it's also likely to create shortages of
food
as there is not enough to properly
irrigate crops
according to the international
federation of the red cross and red
crescent societies
more than 13 million afghans do not have
enough food to eat
the covet 19 pandemic has created
economic hardships for many
but now if help isn't provided for food
in a few months 18 million afghans
almost half the population could be
affected
this is the planting series which comes
always after spring
but the conditions are there that
there's no precipitation enough the
moisture on the ground
and then they won't be able to plant so
that's one projecting
in coming months there will be reduced
food availability and as i mentioned the
study that they'll be around 16 to 27
percent
reduced yields in wheat alone and that
will have an impact
what means you'll spend a lot of money
to import which in order to satisfy the
local markets but also because of that
the forces of supply and demand will
mean the prices will also go up
in 2018 the afghan government adopted
a drought risk management strategy and
received a grant from the world bank in
february
to fight drought this year and though a
drought has not been officially declared
yet in afghanistan
the farmers of kalahagi say if no action
is taken
now their fate may resemble that of
other villagers decades ago
we had this kind of drought about 60 to
70 years ago
and the people back then left this area
but after some years they came back when
the water reappeared
and now this disaster is on its way
again
felio contra fury al jazeera kabul